[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a revista digital
donde abordamos los temas más
importantes del ciberespacio y las redes
sociales y los medios de comunicación de
américa latina y el mundo
ante la situación de kobe 19 ahora
trabajamos desde casa dos países de
américa latina fueron recientemente a
las urnas méxico renovó más de 20.000
cargos públicos y la forma en que el
poder quedó distribuido en la capital
llevó a usuarios en redes sociales a
hacer comparaciones con la alemania
dividida tras la segunda guerra mundial
pero por su parte escogí a presidente en
uno de los comicios más polarizados de
su historia y las acusaciones de fraude
sin fundamento motivaron a los
ciudadanos a usar internet como una
herramienta de verificación al proceso
electoral empezamos
e iniciamos esta edición de revista
digital en mexico donde un hecho curioso
marcó las elecciones a las alcaldías en
la capital y los internautas no lo
dejaron pasar desapercibido el domingo 6
de junio se celebraron los comicios más
grandes en la historia del país los
mexicanos acudieron a las urnas para
renovar más de 20.000 cargos de elección
popular entre ellos las 16 alcaldías que
componen ciudad de mexico morena el
partido del presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador ganó 11 de ellas en 2018
pero este año solo se quedó con 7 estos
resultados dejaron un mapa electoral muy
particular la capital quedó dividida
justo por la mitad mientras la coalición
de morena que integra partidos de centro
e izquierda obtuvo la victoria en las
alcaldías de la parte oriente de la
ciudad la alianza opositora conformada
por los partidos tradicionales se hizo
con la parte occidental
esta demarcación provocó diversas
reacciones en redes sociales por un lado
quienes criticaban la repartición del
poder y por otro quienes aprovecharon
para darle un toque de humor lanzando
una lluvia de memes y es que aunque
parezca pura coincidencia el territorio
que fue marcado con azul al ver que
algunas de las zonas más privilegiadas
de ciudad de mexico mientras que en los
rojos se encuentran algunos de los
sectores menos favorecidos esto llevó a
que los usuarios asociarán dicha
división con el muro de berlín la
estructura que marcó la separación no
sólo física sino también ideológica de
la capital alemana durante la guerra
fría al occidente un bloque capitalista
y al oriente un bloque comunista para
los internautas ahora había una ciudad
de méxico- del este y una ciudad de
méxico- del oeste y bromearon con que se
necesitaría un pasaporte para cruzar de
un lado al otro
porque surgen estas comparaciones de qué
impacto tienen en la sociedad mexicana
se lo preguntamos a ana laura montiel
experta en marketing político y
estrategias digitales en realidad
digamos que todos estos meses que
circulan en redes sociales pues bueno
tienen la intención un poco de dividir
yo diría que tienen dos visiones una es
mostrar que se ganó la mitad de la
ciudad de mexico que durante muchos años
estuvo en manos de el perredé y
posteriormente de morena pero que
digamos que son prácticamente los mismos
y de pronto en esta elección el pan
logra quitarle la mitad de la casa
actualmente a claudia sheinbaum que es
la jefa de gobierno y entonces bueno
pues la oposición está tratando de
enfatizar al máximo que crees en esta
elección te ganamos la mitad de tu casa
esto lo único que va a hacer es
polarizar y luego último que queremos en
este país y en esta ciudad es polarizar
los ánimos es hacer claras
otras diferencias que desafortunadamente
todavía existen en nuestro país y en la
ciudad de mexico pasamos ahora a perú
que también acudió a las urnas para
escoger a su nuevo presidente y los
ciudadanos estuvieron muy activos en
internet al momento de grabar este
programa las autoridades habían
contabilizado más del 99.5 por ciento de
las actas y el candidato de izquierda
pedro castillo llevaba una estrecha
ventaja sobre su adversaria de derecha
keiko fujimori los votantes utilizaron
internet como una forma de verificar el
proceso electoral pero las noticias
falsas no se hicieron esperar por medio
de su cuenta de twitter las autoridades
electorales salieron en defensa del
escrutinio y asumieron como
verificadores de fec news como por
ejemplo esta publicación que dice que si
no se votaba con un bolígrafo azul la
máquina que procesa las papeletas no lo
leería la oficina nacional de procesos
electorales aclaró que el conteo de los
votos lo hacen de manera manual los
miembros de la mesa integrantes del
jurado especial de elecciones de perú
realizaron audiencias públicas para
resolver las situaciones de los votos
que habían sido
y la transmisión que se llevó a cabo en
sitios oficiales y canales de televisión
fue todo un evento para los peruanos más
de 70 mil personas llegaron a conectarse
en uno de los canales para observar en
vivo que estaba pasando con los votos a
sus candidatos durante la reunión se
observó que un gran número de papeletas
que fueron declaradas nulas contenían
dibujos en fotografías de pedro castillo
y que con fujimori los espectadores
tomaron capturas de pantalla e inundaron
las redes sociales con varios memes así
como también cuestionaron la
invalidación de los votos que a su
juicio fueron emitidos de forma correcta
medios de comunicación han planteado sus
preocupaciones sobre el proceso
electoral en perú y el futuro que le
espera quien asuma las riendas del país
y han dedicado sus editoriales a este
tema en eeuu en washington post titula
perú un país víctima de irresponsables y
cuestiona la actitud de quienes han
lanzado acusaciones de fraude sin
pruebas el país de españa dice la hora
crucial para perú también aborda el tema
de las acusaciones de fraude y señala
que ambos candidatos deben entender que
lo que está en juego es el futuro de
perú y que la democracia es un sistema
de convivencia que obliga al respeto a
las normas
elperiódico la tercera en chile dice el
futuro incierto de perú plantea que con
un congreso fragmentado y un país
polarizado quien asuma la presidencia
deberá estar dispuesto a hacer
concesiones para darle viabilidad a su
gobierno y no ahondar la inestabilidad
política
hasta aquí revista digital recuerda que
si quiere repetir esta u otra emisión de
nuestro programa lo puede hacer a través
de nuestra página web www puntos 24
punto com
[Música]